Now we are going to do a slightly
more detailed directory example,
to show how the directory doesn't
become a bottleneck when a bus would.
Here we have four cores,
each with its own cache and also,
next to each core is
a slice of the directory.
Let's assume that each slice
just keeps track of one block.
So this is the directory slice where
we keep the block X information,
and then next to cache one
there is directory Y, Z and W.
And now let's assume that
the core 0 write X at about
the same time,
where core 1 is trying to read Y.
This is a cache miss, and we send
the request to the directory that is
the home for X, which happens to be
around nearby slice of the directory.
When we read Y we go to our own slice.
Let's say that cache 2 also
reads Y at about the same time.
So what happens now is the write to X,
and
the read to Y here are probably going to
be processed at about the same time,
completely independently
by these directories.
Meanwhile, the read Y is travelling
through the network to this directory.
In each of these directories, we see
that the block is not present in any of
the caches, so we allow exclusive access
for the read, and here, of course,
the block will be modified, anyway, so
here, we will set the dirty bit and
note that block X is now in the cache 0,
and
here we will set the dirty bit because
exclusive can become dirty easily, and
set the presence bit for cache 1.
Now the read Y is traveling
to this directory,
let's say that cache 1 is being
accessed with a write to X and
it's a cache miss so
it gets sent to this directory.
So this will probably arrive here first.
We will check the presence vector and
the dirtiness information and
see that cache 1 is the one that has the
data, and that it might be dirty there.
So we forward the request
to read to cache 1.
Cache 1 acknowledges that request,
changes its state to shared,
we get the response that
it doesn't carry data,
so now we know that the block was not
dirty, and we change it to not dirty.
We then get the data and forward it
to cache 2, and now we know also that
cache 2 might have the data, and that
cache 2 eventually will get the data,
so it will eventually get
the shared state and the block Y.
Meanwhile, the write X is getting here,
and because we need to write we're
going to send an invalidation and
an external write request to cache 0,
so here the cache needs to responds with
the data because it's a write request,
it sets the state to invalid and
responds with the data.
This is also a write, so the block will
remain dirty, but now the directory
knows that cache 0 no longer has the
data, and we send the data to cache 1.
So now the cache 1 will eventually get
the data in the modified state, and, as
you can see, the write to X and the read
to Y are largely proceeding independent
of each other, except for maybe
possible connection in the network.
So, if our network is good and has many
different paths between these caches and
directories, then really,
there was no point where these requests
competed with each other for anything.
This one was processed by this cache and
this directory, this one was processed
by this cache and this directory, and
we involved other caches if necessary.
But in this case, it was this cache, so
these requests were still
largely independent.
Now let's say we want to
write to Y in this cache.
This will be sent to the directory for
Y.
So the message travels over here.
The directory for
Y now sees that caches 1 and
2 might have the data and
that none of them are dirty, so
it just sends the invalidation
request to caches 1 and 2.
When they receive this
invalidate the block Y and
send back responses that
indicate that they have done so.
When the first response arrives from,
let's say, cache 1,
the directory eliminates this bit.
When the second response comes,
Now that we know there are no more
remaining sharers we can send the data
to the requesting writer and note
that it's going to have the block and
that the block will be dirty.
So now we send the block over here and
this block becomes modified here and
so on.
So again this write only
involved the caches and
the directory entry that actually
needed to be involved for this block.
This cache and directory, for example,
were completely operating independently
of this, and these two directories
could've done something else.